Biden building miles of border wall is
especially shocking given the repetitive
drum
beat we have a process in place to
manage migrants at the border the border
is secure but we also have a broken
immigration system the fact of the
matter is the border is closed it is my
testimony that the border is secure the
United States will continue to enforce
our laws and secure our border the
president has done more to secure the
border and to deal with this issue of
immigration than anybody else I want to
be very clear our borders are not
open Republican congresswoman cat ca
Florida a member of the House Homeland
Security and agricultural committees
look when you listen to us rolling back
the tape those were lies and there's no
other way to put it because you couldn't
just flip a switch and get what we have
like five minutes ago no no Harris it's
good to see you and know that is
absolutely a lie for the last 3 years we
have seen Biden and all of his
administration officials tout the line
that the border secure I've been there
myself nine times and I have seen the
trafficking I have seen the National
Security crisis I have seen the
apprehension of international terrorists
on the watch list as people are saying
oh no it's totally fine it's not this
has turned every single town in America
into a Border Town and it is directly
Joe Biden's fault from his lack of
action and then to lie on top of it well
that's just unacceptable
well and your Governor Dan santis in
Florida really got their attention when
he sent you know like 50 illegal
immigrants who'd come across the border
up to Martha's Vineyard the precious
country of Elites of those liberals who
just loved party there it got their
attention but it didn't change their
policy it didn't change until those
cities were crippled by what the Border
deals with every day you're so right
about that all right let's get to this I
can't wait to hear what you have to say
about New York city mayor Eric Adams
he's he started his Day in Mexico City
the first leg of a 4-day stop in Central
and South America and the goal he says
is convincing people not to come to New
York City now Chicago mayor Brandon
Johnson is planning a trip of his own oh
my goodness they're all going to go to
the Border can't they take the president
with them the influx of illegal
immigrants is causing chaos in his city
as well watch assist the full situation
and that also requires our team to be at
the border I've heard that the goal is
to convince migrant not to come to
Chicago during winter time is that true
no thousands of illegal immigrants have
been sleeping in Chicago police stations
and at airports as they wait to be
placed inside shelters the number of
people bust in from the southern border
is expected to double and by the way
that is courtesy of the federal
government we'll get into that in a
moment residents Furious that precious
resources now are not going to them and
they are angry over their tax dollars
being spent this
way
us us I want mayor Brandon Johnson to
understand that you're selling us out
for people who can't vote for
you yeah we come in a community of black
people where we already get the low
scraps and then you want to take the
little scraps the resources that we have
and put us at the bottom of the AR
that's not fair and I won't have it wo
congresswoman there's a lot to react to
yes yes Harris you know I kind of feel
like John mlan in the greatest Christmas
movie of all time Die Hard welcome to
the party pal we have been saying for
years that the border is insecure that
the Biden border crisis has turned every
town in America into a border community
and guess what it has and now this
Administration and blue States and blue
cities all across America are going to
pay the price and so now we get 20 mi of
Border by the way they have to violate
26 federal laws to do that but the law
has never really mattered to them and I
think part of the thing that needs to
happen for all these blue cities and all
these blue States and certainly the
White House they got to admit they were
wrong the first step to fixing a problem
is admitting you were wrong and we know
that Trump derangement syndrome is
exceptionally alive and well at the
white house right now so they need to
First admit that Trump was right they
were wrong that border that the border
wall is effective it is a force
multiplier that technology is helping in
pushing back against the illegals coming
across the border and guess what putting
America First works that is why people
are so mad that's especially important
for the people who voted for Biden it's
important for people to know the truth I
don't know how many of them might be
watching Fox and can see all of our
coverage from stem to stern but for it
to come from the White House would be
critical I won't hold my breath I'm
guessing you won't either but when you
flip the previous president's policies
into effect again and start to build a
wall that that'll that's sufficient for
a short-term start a lot of critics are
pointing to the free resources provided
to certain illegals select state and
local governments are providing housing
and cash assistance Education Health
Care food and legal support and on the
federal level assistance of All Sorts is
available to see
immigrants with qualified status here's
a scroll of those including Medicaid and
Social Security and while we scroll
congresswoman talk to me about
fairness listen the United States is the
most generous Nation on this planet we
are the most compassionate people in the
world and I agree that there is
absolutely a system in place to help
people but it has been exploited it has
been abused and now it is broken and
America Americans are paying the price
we are being taken advantage of and that
has to change if you continue to put
Americans last you will have no one to
take care of folks who need help you
will not have a system that is
well-funded to do this and we have our
own people here at home our veterans who
are being pushed out and onto the
streets we have workingclass families
that pay their taxes that do everything
right and they're being punished by the
Biden administration because the Biden
Administration
wants to and we know this they want to
make sure that you don't have to have an
ID to vote and you don't have to be a
citizen to vote and they will do
anything to keep power here in this city
they will do anything to maintain
control that is why they want to grow
the government they are entirely ryant
on this agenda of dependency and control
and Harris when you think about it and
we've we you and I have talked about
this when you think about that all they
want to do is keep people dependent on
big government programs so that they may
in control and fixing the problem means
that they lose leverage by persisting
the problems they stay in Power
Solutions they lose leverage that is why
fixing the border is so critical it's
not just National Security it's not just
the humanitarian thing to do it's not
just about putting Americans first it is
about breaking the system that is
keeping Americans down it is about
breaking the system that is keeping
everyone beholden to big government and
the draining of the swamp is absolutely
what we need to be focused on yeah uh
congresswoman kamik thank you very much
for being with me in focus for all of
those important reasons I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis